how do we teach kids how do we make it
easy for kids help kids learn how to
read because despite is technology and
bells and whistles if you can't read you
can't do a damn thing with the internet
we can so we need to do a better job
it's still about the fundamentals we
don't teach kids how to read in this
country anymore we don't teach them how
to go abcdefg we don't send Dick and
Jane they're not kids don't know how to
read and no matter which is that reading
is everyone says no one reuses anymore
people read all the time everything they
look at is reading you can't design you
can't design web programs you can't read
so how without the fundamentals of what
the building block of civilization is
you know we're in chaos it you know you
go to a place like London everyone reads
they read well and there's a reason why
I think their culture is pretty still
vibrant and now this is kind of dumb
when you done when you don't have people
who read or mastered read and it can
inform themselves through reading then
then you have a very passive bunch of
sheep who are very vulnerable to leaders